hello my name is david valenta i am the
lvmpd special victims lieutenant in
charge of the animal cruelty unit
in conjunction with the bureau of land
management we are asking for the
public's assistance in an ongoing
investigation into horse shootings at
the cowboy trail rides inside the red
rock conservation area
the first event occurred in january of
2022 and since then there have been
three additional events in march
june in the early morning hours of july
4th these crimes have all occurred at
night
these shootings are intentional and the
suspect is actively concealing his
identity
in the video and photos you will see the
suspect has a ski mask gloves and is
wearing ear protection
the suspect is believed to park in the
area then walk onto the property and go
to the horse corral each horse has been
shot at close range
this suspect should be considered armed
and dangerous
we are asking citizens to watch the
videos and if anything seems familiar
about the suspect or if you have seen a
suspicious vehicle parked in the area or
have any related information please call
the lvmpd's animal cruelty unit at
702-828-3360
or email us at animal cruelty lvmpd.com
if you wish to remain anonymous
call crimestoppers at
thank you for 702-385-5555 time
you